[Music]
you were an original judge on X Factor
UK this is ten eleven years ago a long
time ago and now you look and back then
there was your show and American Idol
now there's I think six hundred singing
competition shows how do you feel about
the other shows if one more person
stands in front of me and sings I tell
you I've had it with people singing at
me and I've had it watching people
singing on TV so you think something
wrong to be either got one lung one
kidney or they came up like this or like
that and the Volvo
they've all got somebody sick in
hospital and it's like Oh Lord just shut
up and sing but then when they sing it's
like please stop it I can't take it
anymore and it doesn't matter love where
the chair revolves or you look at them
or you don't know so you don't like the
whole thing the voice does of the chair
revolving whether it's they're here and
no because they're making it like it's
just the voice everything that matters
is the voice will hold on here that's
great when you're but ugly and you're
like
[Applause]
do you think you know what the boys
would be better if you could then spin
back around again
oh good show
[Music]
[Applause]
would show what we want to see and all
this niceness and everything but you
think you're willing to not you think
people are being too nice on these shows
Oh some guy that looks like Meatloaf's
offspring around on stage on some bloody
talent show and everybody's going oh you
rock your Rockets like oh shut up love
sandy bones right right he's doing a
meatloaf wannabe tribute band send him
to a bar in Vegas love put meatloaf on
Drebin shove off yeah okay
so you're not having any of that you
think they're too contrived boring
boring boring if I see another judge cry
I tell you please yeah they're always
cry boys like that really move me do you
think they're putting fake drops on as
soon as they've gone out the door we all
bloody crack up laughing yeah so the
whole thing's a sham I can't say for
other people I can't say yeah I'm just
on it down it you're sick of people
singing at you people really do come up
to you on the street and start singing
and say oh I hope my cousin sings would
you listen to their tape
[Applause]
that's fantastic
god yes I'm just imagining people also
just break into song in your face don't
think they just start it happened when
I've been on planes a couple of
Stewart's I'm like don't be singing at
me darling look at the bloody even work
it into the conversation do they just
come up to say like son coffee
yeah you're like
[Applause]